a big narrative that we were hearing
about your artists not anymore right
they changed it to the phone calls that
was the initial narrative which was a
lie that's a tactic of the left so let's
play let's do the context here yeah
you put out a video you mentioned look
at these fees
it's you know I I never mentioned money
outside of what I believe were immoral
penalty fees I never talked you've never
heard me say hey not enough money was
offered that's not what it's about so
when we when we first were watching the
show and we talked about it I said
what's the fee we don't know and then
the daily wise response of course was we
offered this guy 50 million dollars
basketball money basketball money the
response then from detractors and most
people was holy crap and they're
imagining Stephen Crowder in a big
private bank vault diving into a budget
when in reality the 50 million dollars
included the entire budget for your
whole staff your whole production
facility every production you would have
done meaning you've got to pay how many
employees you have about 25 soon to be
30 something soon to be 30 something now
if you want to do production on a skit
we're talking maybe 30 to 50K depending
on the size of the skit yeah every time
we show up to a change my minus fifty
thousand dollars millions in legal yeah
millions millions of dollars in
equipment payroll uh millions of dollars
in taxes it's the merging it's the
merging of what was that it's theft yes
let me just say wheelhouse I'm I'm on
your side on this one everybody can know
my bias the reason that really bothered
me is because I run a company I know how
much money we make and there are people
who assume that Revenue equals money in
your pocket profit and it's like no no
if they're giving them 50 million
dollars it sounds so wonderful they're
assuming you're dumb they're they're
treating the audience like they're dumb
again a lot of people don't nobody
nobody don't understand this people
don't understand because they're
assuming that you won't go into research
look 50 million basketball money versus
12 million if if let's say Marvel says I
know the new Thor movie is 200 million
dollars is that Hemsworth's salary it's
that simple of an analogy yeah but the
issue here and I'll let Jill kind of
talk about that more the the issue here
is like I think that these people at
Daily wire they've said that they're
very business savvy they're running a
business so are they very business savvy
um and no are they dumb and don't know
that 12.5 million dollars a year for an
entire production house is what we're
actually looking at or are they lying
when they say it's basketball money and
50 million dollars I think Candace owns
at one point got up to like 140 or
something on the I don't I don't said
you wanted 30 million a year or 140. the
only reason people people know that's
not true and you've seen the transcript
you ever see me once say hey it's about
more money there was never an offer sent
after I said look it's a non-starter if
you don't change these these terms and
please tell me that you're not doing
this with other people there was never
anything after that whereas of course
the non-starter is I'm not gonna I can't
do five libraries because
I just want to ask one specific question
because a lot of people are bringing
this up and they're accusing you guys of
only exposing them after they turned
down your counter offer is that true or
can you add more information to that
yeah I don't know why they're saying the
timeline that he kind of gave was
completely inaccurate yeah there was
never there was never any counter offer
from us what Stephen said was basically
look guys these are the terms that we
have a problem with right and if this I
don't care what the contract says Dollar
Wise if these terms are in there that's
bad and you need to start again this has
to be pulled out so there was no counter
offer because I'm seeing a lot a lot of
you guys saying there's the agent the
agent I think my agent the first they
sent this term sheet agent said well if
you're talking about 100 ownership by
the way in perpetuity forever meaning
and it's a six-year contract with no
option to negotiate they have an option
to extend for two years six years locked
in at that rate and again right how do
you penalize someone for money that they
don't make they're not going to lose
money on you being demonetized now I get
that I'm a special situation but this is
demanded of everybody the big con issue
is something that I've been running up
against and everyone in this industry
knows for many many years they just were
arrogant enough to out themselves and to
put it in writing and to say we know how
to run this business we've figured it
out you don't know what you're talking
about and of course you know after that
uh um another last job was you know then
going and trying to take
take our our social media director and I
only showed you that email because he's
willing for me to show you like whatever
people posted all the time when you have
your ideas stolen and they put more
money money behind it not just mine when
you build someone up and someone else
comes in and says hey we'll offer you
more money they use them for six months
and burn them out I'm sure that's an
accident I'm sure the people at the top
of daily wire didn't know when they
reached out to someone who was not
looking for a job who loudly and proudly
advertises himself as social media
director for later with Crowder but I
could tell you that on that phone call
they said we have an entire social media
department where I said I have one guy
Gary and he's awesome
a few days later I do want to dedicate
more to Gary join daily wire well let me
know I know they came and tried to hire
him I wanted for John I want to dedicate
some more time to go starting from the
beginning of the context of that story
but I wanted to uh address something
before Luke jumped in the uh I Dare You
Luke yeah how dare you Luke
go to the floor that was a good question
you know I had I want to put attack on
this and um one of the one of the big
things we're hearing is uh a friend you
know that you know you guys were friends
and uh the recording of the phone call
and stuff and I just thinking about the
contract yeah four four-year contract
with an option to renew for two locking
you in at that rate 12.5 including the
entirety of your staff
and it's just business and I'm kind of
like you know I hear that it's not
something friends offer their friends no
is it is it boilerplate we send this to
everybody or is it a friend you know
what it costs to have a lawyer Mark up a
term sheet it ends up being thousands of
dollars especially when it's like hey
look hit select all delete none of this
makes sense this isn't for someone who's
been demon but the problem and that's
one it came down to while you're in that
phone call this I said take me out of it
right this is not the right fit period I
knew that please tell me that these are
not the terms that are demanded
penalties that you are monetized on
YouTube that you remain on Facebook that
you stay in please tell me these are not
the terms that are demanded of everybody
and I said that was those are the last
words he said yeah you know maybe I'll
take it under advisement and then you go
okay all right this is where we are
there's no hope for the movement if we
claim to be fighting big Tech and we
sell out the people who are paying us to
do so and fighting on behalf of big Tech
I'm sorry it is something it's wrong
earlier earlier in the show you
mentioned that uh I think you mentioned
this in the show that you were you were
in Hollywood you were uh doing the
standard Talent route and then you
decided to come out on YouTube as a
conservative and it basically cost you a
lot you you lost your manager I I don't
you don't you don't come off uh to me as
a lot of you know Candace was on the
show and she said he's doing it for
money it's so obvious why can't people
see it and I'm just I'm thinking about
that and I'm like do you believe that no
I don't well they're accusing you of
counter-offering but but I understand
that but my first my the first thing I
thought was I'm like Crowder's already
rich you know what I mean like I
understand people are looking at
contracts really like you think I mean
if they want to do if they want to do
personal tax returns and business tax
returns and the charitable givings we
can do that this is this is uh we can do
that again do it through a third party
and seal them because I get private
information we can do that Gerald will
tell you this is again you know uh
people like why why I care about the
subject matter so much running this
business and making lots of money I
often say for a guy like me who growing
up in Chicago and being close to the
bottom of the totem pole as an American
which is great for the rest of the world
I mean if you for the rest America's
awesome right the poorest person is
wealthy compared to everybody else right
but there's a certain point in terms of
having things that I could have ever
wanted and it's a very very low bar
right you know I'm making once once I
got hired by Disney the Disney Fusion
they're paying me 250k I'm staring at
money I have no idea what to do with
right beyond that I'm going to change
the world I'm gonna do everything I can
but this is the thing that dialogue
shifted to money money money you heard
me say this is wrong and then it's money
money just a business and then it's this
is wrong money money money money this is
just a business look it's not just a
business and by the way when you're
talking about business find out what
motivates the people you're in business
with I'm not motivated by money that's
not what motivates me if you look back
at the track record in 2009 I it was
because I wanted to see the system burn
meaning as far as the system that kept
conservatives in line and I'm in the
liberal system but then when you realize
that it's on your own side not motivated
by money and by the way don't leave
someone don't leave someone with nothing
to lose you know the easiest situation
is take the money shut up second easiest
is go bet on yourselves you've seen the
numbers that we've given you there and
guess what you make more money you shut
up the the option of say no and say look
this is wrong and speak out is
significantly harder than any of the
other paths the two things I want to say
is uh my point on the money was I view
you in a similar way way that you're
ideologically driven that if you have
the resources to do what you want to do
and you're living comfortably and taking
of your family beyond that I don't see
you as the kind of guy who's like I
don't have an infinity pool and three
Ferraris in my garage so when they say
Crowder is just what's the infinity pool
is that the edge it's where the edge
goes off like and so yeah it looks like
a horizon no idea that sounds nice I
mean I wouldn't mind but the question is
if you had the choice between an
infinity pool and a young you know a
talented personality who is going to
help change the shape of this country
for the better yeah I think you're going
to choose the change the shape of this
country for about that's my view of you
100 I had to tell this guy that it was
okay to buy a reasonably priced shotgun
yes I'm not kidding this is this this is
not me like well he is Canadian
we've been friends for a while Stephen
can tell me at any point to go pound
sand right so I'm not kissing up this is
it's just like he's like geyser
I want to buy the shotgun I'm finale
yeah
I have the foldable stock yeah is it
basketball money crazy expensive no no
it's not right and so everyone deserves
everyone in America deserves a shotgun a
Benelli too he was two and a half we
were in Texas hold it together and then
you were there when I bought it yeah but
we were we were at a we were at a shop
out here Luke said hey you should buy
that it's really great I buy it and then
he goes I want it I want it instead was
it a Benelli and then I was I was pissed
off because I was like I didn't think I
was like I should have bought this and
then he bought it before man I'm like
wait wait wait wait hold on this is the
whole argument John was by the way how
many how many people are watching right
now 150 000 ish 158 on our Channel 158
000. so what what 158 is that a 150
that's just on your channel that's why
we're still streaming on ours I think
second highest number we've ever done
okay I just on our YouTube alone uh did
you want to translate no so no it wasn't
really a point was the Benelli M4 right
so what happened is I really want it but
they're not cheap and I was like you
know what I can't justify buying I
should go buy it online and so I was
talking with Gerald and and Johnny Boy
Who You Met My Canadian friend I said
okay you know what if I go into it
because you know they're like unicorns
they sell out right away I said if I go
into a gun store to pick up something up
or something and it happens to be there
that's God telling me he wants me to
have a Benelli M4 and I I went to go
pick up some transfers from from Walther
and lo and behold I see one there just
came in and it's the uh the H2O version
the cerakoted version and I don't think
you're with me but Johnny boy was and I
was like ah you know I I still don't
think I could justify it he said if you
don't pay for it I'm going to buy it uh
and of course I knew that it would be
far more expensive for him so I I bought
it but it took a long time I'm not
really motive but it is a nice shotgun
though I will say yeah occasionally
there are some things that we're going
to spend money on oh a tool any tool
that you want to learn something with
like a guitar too you want to get good a
really good tool yeah or like knives
like if I have like there's a huge with
steel and that's okay sorry Tim I know
I got to make a point about you said in
2009 you you were like you realize that
the liberal system is you know holding
you back or something to the effect and
then you've actually realized it's on
your side as well yeah I look over to
Luke because Luke's the guy who's been
screaming since 2006 like the Republican
machine is lying to you all the same the
powers that were being given to the
Intel agencies and the establishment
will be used against you yeah here we
are well here's the thing you're
absolutely right and uh let's be honest
right how can you change all that
yourself you're doing the best that you
can right but there's only so much that
you can do the difference is right now
at this point an inflection point
history as it relates to right-wing
conservative media I can do something I
can't change the intelligence agencies
but you know what when I asked Carrie
Lake on the show I say would you disband
the FBI yeah I would boom gone suspended
I can do something about that I can't
change the CIA or the FBI you're
probably more effective with that than I
am I'm an entertainment guy was a guy
telling jokes in in clubs having beer
bottles thrown at me when I was 17 years
old voicing in you know a black bear who
was the best friend of an aardvark when
I was 12 which is clearly derived from
hallucinogenic drugs um I love that show
yeah you know it's funny I had to do the
Kwanzaa rep if everyone finds something
embarrassing for the Christmas episode
and that's when I was 13 years old and I
was like oh Kwanza and I was like let me
look into this I should you know Daniel
Day Lewis this and uh then I realized oh
it's it's Ron Everett and he
beat them with fire hoses and soldering
irons and then I'm doing this song for
Arthur hey come together now it's
Kwanzaa time and I wanted to pay worth
it what's that point you know I was
under I didn't I was under contract at
12 years old right you know so there's
not much you can do I still remember we
were called crazy truthers for for
calling this out as rationally as we did
saying hey the National Security State
is going to be turned around against you
and it has but
at that time specifically we we had a
discourse that was kind of free and open
we didn't have algorithms people were
able to see important messages and
videos and talking points and content
creators now we're living in a different
age I wanted to kind of get your point
of view some people say you have to keep
pushing the Overton window some people
say you got to keep playing ball Mark
Dice is also in the chat he just is
accusing Ben Shapiro of allegedly paying
135 000 to boost his Facebook posts I
don't know if that's but that's true
well who cares though he can do that the
the only thing I have is one the only
issue I have is one that's used and it
hurts people because sponsors drop out
because they don't get their money's
worth again I can tell you that but with
those receipts be a betrayal because
this industry fundamentally needs to
change people are investing in you and
in us and in what you're saying right if
you can't say what it is that you're
saying right now let's say if you send a
contact said yeah but you know what we
have a lot of buddies in those in those
systems you're selling out the people
who are supporting you and that's
something that to me is unconscionable
and people can disagree with it but no I
think you're I I think you're absolutely
right
I want to get into the the problem
solving like what would you do if you
were the daily wire okay so the only
thing and this is the thing this is all
done right now I don't I'm not saying
that I have all the answers but the
first answer and I said we won't talk
about this again if someone takes a
pledge alongside me anyone in VidCon
just the only thing that I ask is that
you do not punish conservative content
creators on behalf of big Tech that's it
start with that let's start with that
before we get to everything else right A
lot of times people want the entire
solution just start with that you won't
be penalized 25 if you're demonetized on
YouTube by the people who are supposed
to be fighting for you now let's address
the the the the argument there yeah the
argument they've made is how do why
should we be the ones to lose money if
you're removed from the platform and not
making money and that sounds really
great right it's a partnership that's
what they were talking about they were
trying to pick like a partnership and
put it into contract form or at least in
this you know like a term sheet right
well what it didn't take into account
honestly is what if what if Stephen okay
it's 12 and a half million what if he's
making them 30. what if he's making them
30 million
yeah what if he's making up 30 million
dollars a year and all of a sudden
instead of making 30 they're you
subtract two from that so it's fine to
share in these things when the expenses
come up but when the upside comes up
we're not really in a partnership
anymore
we would be
right there
okay
you're a wife this is a good point it
penalized you
it's if you get banned you lose X
percent
and no matter how much you're making 45
no matter how much you're making no and
no matter how much you lose yeah yeah if
you lose zero dollars they penalize and
the penalties add up to 110 and they
said in their own this is demanded of
all creators right that's does anyone
disagree that that's what we said this
is what everyone signs now now here's
the issue with that again you don't put
it in if you don't want that the counter
the Counterpoint Candice said is she
negotiated she hired a lawyer yeah
Stephen Crowder has the resources to
hire a lawyer and Redline this sure she
put on her I thought we were good
friends
I figured out why why Candace was so
pissed last night yeah because I figured
it out in a second thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time